which is a form of therapy right yeah
but that's therapeutic it's not therapy
yeah those are two different things like
and um i think that's something that uh
a lot of guys don't understand right
yeah they think that oh it's like oh wow
when i kick it with my boys i come back
home and i feel really great
that's awesome i think that's super
great he's like yeah i could tell my
boys like my day was stressed out that's
great
but the difference between that and once
again i'm not trying to push therapy
hard on everybody else
i just think that if you do need help
it's very important for you to get
professional help oh are we recording
in five four three two
hello everybody welcome to genius brain
she cannot help herself but to always do
accents
i kid you it is either a nervous tic or
something but every time dude let me
tell you what she did the other day what
did i do
okay
so we got i know what you're doing we
got postmates right
and there's this our post-based guy is
an asian dude
clearly he doesn't speak english very
well well how do you know he didn't say
a sing award oh because i was messaging
him for the food stuff he's all broken
english and his name is asian as [ __ ]
and he's an older asian gentleman
she comes in she goes oh after she drops
out the food she opens the door gets the
package looks at this guy and she goes
okay thank you
first of all give me anxiety
[Laughter]
clarification when they say stop asian
hate they're talking about you
clarification
he wasn't even looking at me he was
walking towards his car and i wasn't
thinking oh he's asian so let me bring
up my asian accent that's just who i am
okay thank you
i'm like okay thank you because that's
exactly what i do 24 7.
and here's the thing i thought about
this i was like huh why do i do that you
know it turns out that
what i actually do is mimic americans
how was that mimicking an american
joe not that some cute part what are you
talking about
but i've realized that when i'm talking
like this
i'm actually
mimicking american accent
explain i have no idea what you're
talking about so did you do ayahuasca
before we started this are you liking
another dimension what the hell are you
saying right now you're not in the same
world as me that's what it is it's
mind-blowing i don't think everybody is
i don't know what you're talking about
so i had a conversation with my friends
talking about like what our first
languages and everything and i was like
i don't have a freaking first language
it's like is that english not really is
it korean not really and what is it i'm
like what is the first language you
learned korean yeah so your first
language is crazy no but i didn't learn
korean well so when i went to korea i
didn't know how to speak korean
so it's
what it turns out is that i don't have a
language in terms of like and that also
equivalents to
equates equates to
the accent that i have so when i'm
talking in english as well i only picked
this up recently 2015 to be exact oh no
2014 2013 to be exact
uh it's a very specific date for you to
remember this it's cause when i came
back from taiwan and i didn't know how
to communicate i was like in a very like
dark world
and then i started uh having internships
and stuff so that's when i started
listening to the americans saying like
you crushed in mario i'm like why the
hell what does that even mean why are
you yelling at me and then i realized
there's all these like idioms that they
use so i started listening and realizing
oh that's how they talk
so i mimic it
what does that have to do with you
looking at that asian man and going okay
thank you what i'm saying is that
i'm not i'm not
being
raped i don't know what do you what are
you trying to say like i'm racist or
something is that
because i'm not trying to i'm not
i thought would have said thank you or
thank you whatever i said i'm saying
that with you you do a lot of stuff
that's very sus
that you need that you need to second
guess when you say things out loud
you do a lot of things where i'm just
like dude you're so lucky that like
either this ethnicity or this type of
person isn't around because whenever she
says stuff she doesn't mean anything by
it it's just it's just she's been around
so so many different countries there's a
lot of things she doesn't understand
like for example one of the things that
shooketh me
and she shook with me what is that what
a lot of people don't understand right
so when they go oh you live in america
you should be used to
all this type of information right one
of the biggest things that i think
people [ __ ] up on is assuming that this
person should know everything that you
know right so for example when it came
to
when it comes to race relation things
um
there was a lot of asian people that i
knew that i didn't know didn't
understand a lot of like black american
culture or the things that that the
black american uh community has to deal
with and people will look at some of
these people and say what are you
[ __ ] living under a rock
you're doing that because you're
ignorant you choose not to know these
things about what you're racist
and that's unfair because we had this
idea of what america is right we think
that everybody in this country lives in
a melting pot and it's not true if you
come into california specifically the
los angeles county i have been so
surprised as to meet so many people who
have never either had an a mexican
friend black friend white friend and
vice versa the other way yeah we're not
a melting pot we're just bubbles people
stay in their little bubble specifically
in this area if you guys don't know
there's an area called uh
diamond bar and roland heights
heavily heavily populated chinese and
korean area right some of these
[ __ ] there they mate they might
see one or two black people their whole
lives yeah and
literally that's it because the people
in their school all look like them you
know how bad it is is that we would go
to albertson's which is a local grocery
store
and if we see a white lady pass by no
joke all of us were like what is she
doing here
just looking at her it's like dude this
is america of course it'll be a freaking
like other race but we're just so used
to having asians around that well this
this actually became a big topic um
years ago on a jk news episode there was
a girl named amber she was i think she's
a taiwanese or she's chinese
um but she was in the k-pop group amber
liu
and amber liu was on here and um it was
a video where some i think a policeman
was harassing uh a black guy right okay
on a subway or something like that it
was something that was pretty bad
and in her mind and she actually they're
like well amber grew up in
let me let's just break it down even
further she made a commentary about how
i wonder why um
that man just didn't listen to the cops
or none of this would happen right and
when you hear that from an outside
perspective and you see somebody who can
speak english who grew up in like the
diamond bar area
they go well you're american what kind
of ignorant [ __ ] is that are you saying
and you know and she got a
a lot of flack from the black community
and just a lot of other people who are
supporting the black human saying like
this woman is you know terrible she's
racist or whatever oh sorry i was trying
to understand what the con what was
happening so basically the cop was
i don't know the exact video but i think
it was a cop that was uh harassing a
black man in the subway and it was like
it was police it was like police
aggression and then she was saying why
couldn't the black man just do follow
the rules listen to the cops or whatever
right and when you say these type of
things and you don't know the history of
this country right and specifically you
don't know what it's like to live here
people look at her and they said well
she's racist well it's not as simple as
that no that girl didn't grow up with
any black people she didn't she doesn't
have a black friend she might have some
black friends here and there in her
periphery that they don't she doesn't
understand the community but when people
look at her they go oh she's an american
she should know better not everybody
knows about this stuff no that's not
i'm a i'm a i'm definitely one of those
candidates
exactly so like you know you know
wrapping it back to you after we
finished this up you know she got a lot
of flack for that and
from an outside perspective people only
thought of her as an american girl she
should know about black plight but she
doesn't just because we live in this
country it doesn't mean that we all know
what's going on right and i used to be
like that too i used to look at some how
do you not know this and then i started
having conversations with people and
seeing how they grew up and they go well
i didn't have any black friends my whole
school was all asian people and a couple
of white people so when it comes to this
type of stuff i just don't know so i
said it from my perspective also too for
her you know i feel like for a lot of
asian people they're
very keen on authority right government
is law so
you just kind of follow along with
whatever like cops in government say so
there's just also this like cultural
thing that a lot of people don't
understand so rapping back to you like i
remember the first time we mentioned
when you met khalif and you wanted to
touch his hair i know and it was
completely innocent
right and then i was like hey you can't
now i clearly know i'm like wow what it
like and the thing is
might have been my first time ever
asking a black person if i could touch
their hair because it might have been
the first time where i had an
opportunity to ask
that's how
a
little opportunity i had to meet
uh african-americans yeah you know i
mean or anyone who had an afro hair yeah
at least i was explaining to her it's
like would you just let any person touch
your hair
it's like oh yeah probably not like yeah
probably not you know there was
something else that was related to that
where
asians get asked a lot
oh i think it's like not equivalent but
it's along the line of this kind of like
agitation of like oh
um do you eat kimchi do you like kimchi
i like kimchi it's like it's not the
first thing you're gonna ask me yeah
yeah yeah just because i'm korean
yeah i mean
i'm even more lenient than that when
people do that type of food stuff i just
go i i find it endearing because that's
the only way they want to relate they
want to connect and relate and you know
what if if the intent is kind yeah i'll
always go for the intent yeah it's stay
it's the intense so guys if i say
something that's
off the line you know just know that the
intent is very innocent yeah and then
just have a conversation and i had this
i was talking about this on a previous
podcast too where i talk about the power
of
conversation right
and conversation is everything which a
lot of people don't want to do nowadays
because it's very easy to go online and
just yell at somebody condemn them and
then try to drag their name through the
mud right when we when we're on this
podcast and i talk about let's say a
topic that um
uh some kind of scandal that happens
this is just a conversation and a
podcast topic there's nothing else to it
we're not really entertaining towards
the camera i'm talking to the person in
front of me but i think what happens a
lot of the times is that a lot of people
are scared of conversation because
they're afraid of confrontation so like
i know a lot of people who want to say
what they want but when the person's in
front of their face they get really
super quiet it's because confrontation
is not in them they don't want to have
conversation majority of the time when
somebody tries to bring somebody down
online it's not because they're trying
to change their mind it's not because
they're trying to make the world better
it's not because they're trying to say
something positive or change somebody's
habit it's because they want to tear
that person down to make them feel
better and so i feel like that's what
happened to amber that's what's
happening to a lot of people nowadays
because like if we mess up
it's like oh
it's not is it impossible for me to make
a mistake you know we we all we all [ __ ]
up
you know that's why that's why i'm
always so open about the things that i
mess up on because i'm not perfect this
is a podcast i'm going to say a lot of
things on this podcast that people
aren't going to agree with and it's just
going to be conversation and thought
even in the last podcast we were talking
and i changed my mind during the podcast
because of the conversation i was having
with pk you know what do you mean oh it
was about a comic who um
uh i felt like he didn't handle this
situation very right and kind of like pk
was just talking to me about well you
know you're different you know like if
if you were in his shoes you probably
would have handled it that way but
he's not like you you know so just to
give him a little empathy and i was like
oh you're probably right but that
wouldn't have happened if it didn't
happen with the one-on-one conversation
people need to learn how to give people
chances and i think that's what we're
missing a lot well those people they
don't want to have that conversation
that's the whole point is that they have
this
uh access of just yelling without having
what's that word it's not it's the
opposite of reward consequence
consequences yeah yeah and it's just you
know they don't they're
they're anonymous and that's they just
want to yell that's it yeah it's like we
don't want a conversation i don't want
you to reply to me i just want to throw
crap at you i always wondered too like
especially during pandemic now or you
know
it's we're still in pandemic but i think
a lot of people have kind of now
wrestled with this idea of
i think
just people are losing their minds dude
like they're losing their minds i'm
losing my mind people are becoming more
and more active on the internet and less
active in real life oh you think it's
still like that oh it's getting worse
and worse even when i see people
vacation or i see people going on trips
they're not i feel sometimes they're not
going on trips with a vacation they're
going on trips to show people they're
going on vacation oh yeah that's been
going on for a while though i'm saying
it's really extreme now it's like oh i
need to go to this spot so i can
tick-tock it versus i need to go because
i want to experience this right you got
to do it for a tech talk yeah it's just
a really odd thing nowadays and i think
like a lot of people now especially like
uh younger people
actually even in our age group
we're
people who live in a first world country
now have this idea of
or this burden of trying to figure out
what makes them happy like happiness is
one of those things that people are
trying are working back towards right
this pandemic has really made people
think about what their happiness means
yeah like what is happiness yeah right
um and i think people are going to find
out a lot of the stuff that you see on
instagram
on social media is just not real like
their happiness is only what they show
you and if you keep comparing your life
to these things that are just snapshots
of of an ideal world that people choose
to show you like this is what yeah this
is what i want to show you but
everything else in the background is
[ __ ] you're going to be chasing
something that's not attainable it's
just not attainable like even when i
show people of you know pictures of our
vacations right
we're not showing them i don't know like
in taiwan we're not showing in the video
i didn't show them us in the airport for
seven hours trying to get a ticket back
because we messed up the dates
you know they're not they're not seeing
that struggle you're only seeing the fun
little when you were vomiting as we were
coming going to taiwan mm-hmm where i
was poisoned
i'm not showing you that type of stuff i
mean we could definitely show that
yeah yeah i'm not trying to show any of
that stuff but we we recently saw a
documentary on this about you know kids
in korea yeah you know when we
obviously my perspective of korea is
based on something that's very dated
right because i was born there but i
came here when i was three years old
and my vision of what korean culture is
actually korean-american culture i
actually don't know too much about
korean korean culture except from the
stuff that my relatives tell me or yeah
you know my parents tell me and that's
really about it so my perspective on
koreans are korean americans in the 90s
in the 2000s right but watching this
documentary it doesn't seem that much
has changed from what my parents have
told me right what's the documentary
that we saw it together the
the one on youtube oh that chosen as
hell
no the one about suicide
that's oh that's what it's called okay
yeah
which is very interesting right so the
in this documentary if you guys watch it
they talk about
kind of like korean culture and this
idea about
like education being the key to
happiness yeah this podcast is brought
to you by purple one of our favorite
ongoing sponsors i love my purple
mattress and if you are sleeping on
something that's not a purple mattress
your spine if it could come out of your
body would beat your ass because you are
screwing with it so much we spend so
much time sleeping in our lives why not
do it with the optimal amount of comfort
and coolness purple mattress has the
grid technology it sleeps and keeps me
cool i'm telling you right now your boy
sweats a lot during the night time and
the grid has helped me out a lot i love
it it's super comfortable and i
seriously don't know what i do without
it purple is comfort reinvented right
now you'll get 10 off any order of 200
or more go to purple.com
brain10 and use promo code brain 10
that's purple.com brain 10 promo code
brain 10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more purple.com
slash brain 10 promo code brain 10 terms
apply right which was established after
like the korean war um
during during that president's time
because this was the way for salvation
it was the idea of education will set
you free yeah so this is the only and
it's been around like that for now many
many years but nowadays whether it's
because of technology or something else
they're finding out that there's
especially with some of these kids that
they interviewed um something very
profoundly they asked a kid like have
you ever thought about your happiness
yeah so i think what they were saying is
that
they picked three students who went to
the top three university in korea which
is called sky um in three different
universities and they came around and
asked them
[Music]
because that would be funny um and then
they basically were saying that they had
goals they had many goals goal is to get
into certain cram school
so that you could get into a certain
university
but they never had the time to think
about what their dream is and that's
what it was which is literally the
saddest thing i've ever heard yeah they
were just like on the go
figuring out how to reach that goal and
that they thought that goal
equivalent
is equivalent to happiness yeah but that
wasn't the case because nowadays so many
of these students or korean
younger i don't know children they who
graduated from school
they're just so many competition now
that they don't have jobs
that they are you know they come out of
school graduated with an honors degree
whatever from this amazing school
turns out that they don't have a job so
it's like
they come out and like what the hell i
thought this was it
like they were at the edge of the cliff
realizing like we they thought it was
the end of
hell instead of like happiness but then
they realize
there's nothing
yeah that's a sad thing and i think too
there's a lot of asian american kids
that go through that same problem
oman apan said you just have to do well
in school and you'll get a great job
when you get a great job you'll be happy
they may not explicitly say that but
because the goal is to make sure that
you get into an amazing school
they think that that's all it takes in
order for you to be happy
right they may not explicitly say it but
it kind of becomes ingrained in them at
a young age right
and so it's like oh well i went to
harvard
and they get this job and the job that
they have pays decently but it doesn't
make them happy
and i think
there's just this huge pressure
specifically with asian americans about
how we look like to other people oh yeah
like that outward image oh where did
your daughter go to school oh my
daughter went to berkeley oh my daughter
went to yale and you know when those
people would ask my parents those
questions like where'd your son go
how's your son
it's so true like in order
in order to be in that community like at
the end of the day we're humans and we
like to be in a community and koreans
are just
heavily focused on status it's all about
saving face having the status so that
people are jealous of you or you know
envious of you and so when you come in
like it's a all competition moms come
around and they talk about their kids
their kids is their pride so however
their kids
result in what school you go to or what
job you get is their pride and is their
like status in the community it's till
the day they die which is so odd like my
mom and i had a very big fight one time
and i think the the thing that i didn't
really understand or care for was the
fact that my dad was uh
he was a minister
so everything that i did came right back
to him you know and
he had to look like he had it all
together our family it wasn't in
shambles or anything but there was a lot
of [ __ ] that we were going through you
know and so i think the the added
pressure of us just trying to keep our
family together on top of that i had to
worry about what somebody else thought
about our family yeah i didn't care for
and you know even afterwards after my
father stopped um stopped his ministry
and he stopped going to church my mom
still had this thing of oh what are
other people going to say and i remember
this conversation that i had with my mom
and i just snapped i was like who the
[ __ ] are these other people who are
these other people and she goes oh you
know the korean i said [ __ ] the korean
community i don't give a [ __ ] about them
i was like if i die tomorrow they might
cry one day but they'll forget about me
the next i don't care if any of them
[ __ ] die tomorrow i wouldn't shed a
[ __ ] tear that's how little i care
about them i was like
and i told my mom this it was such a
crazy fight because i told her i was
like the only person that i care about
is that if you care about me if appa
cares about me if my brother that's it
everybody's a opinion i don't [ __ ]
care don't mention these people to me
you know i feel like
i mean i might be too general but i feel
like men are easier to say that whereas
i don't think it's general i think
that's true like for especially like in
the asian family yeah like for the
daughter to say that it's it's way less
impactful than this moms are more into
this conversation i think maybe because
it's emotionally attached in some way or
they're just more talkative you know
women we love to talk so i think it's
just a lot harder for women to be out of
that society it's just basically you're
saying or to your mom just don't be part
of that society
don't be part of that community and if
that's the only community that she has
well then she's gonna be a loner and who
wants to be alone you know and i could
see the struggle because like i had um a
friend in korea where she had a child
and
she started going to preschool and then
i go and see her and she's like i was
like hi you know how are you doing and
she's like i'm so busy all day every day
because like it's all this like mom's
like gathering and if you miss out they
will kick you out and not only that they
seriously this mom
she is participating everything and
making sure everybody's happy with her
so that her kid
doesn't get outcasted at school because
if the moms decide to outcast her
she will they will tell the kids not to
play with her daughter that's [ __ ]
crazy then it's not so they're doing it
for their kids in that kind of sense
right
so in order to be in this community
her daughter also needs to do well so
that they also think oh this girl has
some resource like we could count on her
but if the girl's kid doesn't do well
school they'll be like oh she's useless
let's kick her out then the kid gets
kicked out do you see how twisted and
intertwined all this stuff is
it's a real life k drama
oh yeah it's real life all these dramas
are not based off like out of nowhere
it's based on some true story yeah you
see a lot of these korean dramas where
they a lot of it talks about status and
respect and it's so important to people
and and i got to tell you like it sucks
to be in a world where that matters it's
it's king status is king
you know i think that's one of the
biggest things that my mom really likes
that she the reason why she enjoyed
moving to the states versus staying in
korea is because of always having to
save face 24 7. it is hard enough trying
to figure out what makes you happy and
to figure out what makes everybody else
happy items i am i hate that so isn't
that sad they're so busy to keeping
other people happy that
individuals they don't know what makes
them happy there's no time for it yeah
it's it's it's stupid right it's like
have you heard of that phrase it kind of
applies to this too it's like
why should why am i drinking poison
praying for you to die
you know what i mean yeah it's like
you're hoping this person dies by you
drinking poison how does that work yeah
that's so true you know like drinking
the kool-aid yeah oh she'll just learn
this new american phrase actually i
already knew that phrase i just didn't
know where it came from yeah well
drinking the kool-aid means like you're
you're following the crowd right so
it's just a it's just a sad thing i i
can't i can't imagine living like that
and even the documentary which i was
surprised
korea's suicide rate beat out japan by a
lot oh yeah long long long long a lot
dude i was like dude korea never lose
baby
korea is number one number one on
everything i was shocked i was shocked
that our suicide rate is that high
uh i mean korea
is basically a replica of japan
so what you know japan was had its own
boom in the early 90s
now it's korea and that equivalence to
having also a high suicide
like our our suicide rate's so freaking
high it's kind of ridiculous man and
like the the emphasis on mental health
in asia really isn't big here's the
thing though i think there is an
opportunity now because there is this
really famous therapist who comes out on
all social media like and all on tv
broadcast too and she is so well
respected because she's helping out not
only celebrities but also just citizens
there are a lot of tv shows where family
come and say i have this problem with my
child so they watch them and she helps
them out and
she has recently i watched the show that
just came on my instagram about um ailee
who is a k-pop artist and she's talking
about her issues and they're having
one-on-one in this tv show and i'm like
whoa they're like really bringing out
issues and talking about in public
how [ __ ] great is that is that
they're finally opening up that people
have issues with their body image with
uh social media how people talk about
each other
and i think it's just
with netflix too just being uh very open
and like these days k dramas are very
open about homosexual
and
it's becoming more and more
um
available for them in social in media
and i think that's a huge
influence for the citizens saying that
hey i need one well i hope so because it
doesn't reflect in the numbers right not
yet so like these tv shows and once
again this is all for profit and benefit
like that's what i'm saying like until i
see that reflection in the numbers where
our su with their suicide rate starts to
drop then i'll believe it maybe she is
coming around because there is
i'm saying like i i seriously doubt
stuff that i see on tv specifically
korean punk some stuff because they
exaggerate [ __ ] to the [ __ ] max just
like any reality tv stuff so therapy no
not just therapy but it's like they do
it because oh people are going to like
this because it gets viewed oh yeah so
i hope that is a reflection in how
everybody else thinks versus it's just
like oh this is an entertaining thing to
watch but it's not for me
because a lot of like korean men are
like that right they they think that
their therapy is them hanging out and
talking to their boys which is a form of
therapy right yeah but that's
therapeutic it's not therapy yeah those
are two different things like and um i
think that's something that uh a lot of
guys don't understand right yeah they
think that oh it's like oh wow when i
kick it with my boys i come back home
and i feel really great
that's awesome i think that's super
great it's like yeah i could tell my
boys like my day was stressed out that's
great
but the difference between that and once
again i'm not trying to push therapy
hard on everybody else
i just think that if you do need help
it's very important for you to get
professional help who cannot tell you
how to live your life but give you
alternative thought to help you work
through your problems because a lot of
people have very similar problems it's
just packaged in different ways yeah you
know yeah and i am so advocate like i
would i'm more than happy to talk to
people about
you know having a therapy and like what
it meant for me personally in my own
opinion of having a therapist it has
changed my life a lot and i am so
advocate about it and you know i think
it's true and one end is like they're
using it because it does bring
the viewer or the view rate
but here's the thing there has been a
lot of shows showing how celebrities
take care of the kids
that got so popular it's just everywhere
right
in return though not only the viewer
rates went up but then they also have a
lot of empathy on these parents it's
like wow not only you're a celebrity but
you're actually a home like you're a
real dad at home you do go through real
struggles like people cry because of the
issues that they're having with their
kids and it's all being shown like it's
so raw i mean obviously it's curated to
a certain story but then certain things
of just like whoa that's kind of just
not the not the
not the not the show but i think that's
not just people so [ __ ] dumb it's
like the moment you know like when
people go into they become a movie star
right it's their job uh-huh they're not
going to stress out too like these
people aren't [ __ ] human it's just
michael jackson it's just like the
weirdest thing though like people people
sometimes treat celebrities like such
[ __ ] like they treat them like they're
[ __ ] commodities and you know what
not all celebrities are great people so
the ones that are terrible go [ __ ]
themselves yeah but you know when when
celebrities come on and they're like
yeah i had a tough day like at work or
you know dealing with my kids and people
ugh what do you mean you have so much
money i know exactly what the [ __ ] does
that have to do with having a healthy
family exactly so these kind of shows
kind of bring the other side of them and
i think this therapy thing
this third
what is the therapy tv shows are gonna
bring that side too it's like i'm not
disagreeing with that i'm just saying
that it's not reflected in our numbers
not yet so i have hope that's what i'm
saying let's see let's see you know
because one of the things that i believe
that korean people are very good at is
showing face really well but then doing
something different in the back end the
younger generation i think is changing
that's why they're in that documentary
there's act there are academics that are
not related to universities yeah it's
hard man because you know i think korea
has been a country that has struggled a
lot you know uh we
like our korean war
um being subjugated under japan and even
beyond that before that we were like we
were
um a province of like china and just you
were just owned we were like poor people
we were poor like we were owned by
everybody it was it was our history is
very sad and i think that's why a lot of
korean americans and you know korean
people out there i don't know if you
agree or disagree we have this this
podcast is brought to you by skillshare
my friends every human was born to
create whether you last picked up a
paintbrush yesterday or in grade school
you can explore your creativity and be
inspired skillshare is an online
learning community that offers
membership with real meaning you got a
bunch of things to explore real projects
create and the support of other fellow
creatives so skillshare empowers you to
accomplish real growth even for me even
though i've been doing youtube and a lot
of online content for a while i decided
to take marcus brownlee's youtube
success script shoot and edit and it
brushes up on a lot of skills that i
forgot about and also teaches me some
new things there's always room to grow
and learn even if it's something that
you've been doing for a long time and
for those of you out there who have side
hobbies and hustles and you're tired of
looking for people to teach you the
right things online well skillshare has
a bunch of classes for you so you don't
have to hunt around and waste your time
and by the way it's also incredibly
affordable an annual subscription is
less than ten dollars a month so explore
your creativity at skillshare.com brain
and get a one month free trial a premium
membership that's a one month of a free
premium membership at skillshare.com
brain scarcity mentality is big in our
country in our culture
like we always feel that somebody else's
success is going to take away from ours
and that we have to do whatever we can
to come up on top
if one of the biggest things that i've
dealt with with a lot of people who are
korean they always had the same story
about somebody who backstabbed them that
was in their korean friends who smiled
in front of their face did something
behind their back and try to climb up on
top and
i i think it just has to do with our sad
history and it's kind of like deeply
ingrained in us to feel that we have to
do whatever we can to survive no matter
what it's always competition it's always
competition and i've i've never ever
liked that and i think because i saw
that so much in the churches a lot of
like korean friends um and once again
this is just my perspective and my life
from what i've seen
and other korean people if you disagree
then i'm glad that you had a better life
than i did but you know it's it's been a
reoccurring thing that i've seen with a
lot of my korean friends yeah
yeah i mean i would say
it's not only korean culture like i've
seen other asian culture that have
similar issues of like backstabbing and
like having
a different plan behind their back um
but i have to say
koreans
there is something called han and ok
is like revenge type of like feeling
like i'll show you we have a lot of
those like i'll show you it's like
japanese people have like uh kriyashi or
something like that like yeah i forgot
what it's called oh they have something
called tatamaya which is completely
opposite we're like very expressive
where them they have this wall so you
never know what they're thinking because
they have such
formal manner and what their mentality
is that you don't
you don't share the pain to others
because then you're bringing um
unnecessary things to them yeah and they
don't like um
what do you call it like shinsegae
burden yeah you want to give burden on
others yeah put um like you don't want
to put them yeah so it's the complete
opposite of koreans where i feel like we
tend to over share that's where the
problem is is that we tend to over share
where people start gossiping
well gossips gossiping is huge in the
so opposite from each other and yet we
are going along the same
lifestyle man i put it like this man
like it's
one of the things what i love about
america is that you could literally be
and do whatever the [ __ ] you want
like you cannot you could say whatever
you want about this country that freedom
alone is something i would never ever
change one of and i just something small
like going to korea or going to other
countries or like going to europe and me
walking around in like shorts and a
shirt it would be like what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing like is he going to play
basketball is he going to swim how come
he's dressed like this they will
definitely look at they'll be looking at
me and in my mind i'm just like i'm
chilling
you know i don't have much pressure to
do that over here i can be with and even
if i lived in korea i still wouldn't
feel that pressure i just would be
making everybody else feel uncomfortable
you know but that's so much work on you
too it's not work because i don't care
so
but you you feel it
you feel that and you know that they're
looking at you so you're reacting but
you and i are different though like
how people behave about how i do
something unless i'm doing something
that's offensive or like hurting them
then i'm gonna be who i am me wearing
shorts and a t-shirt because it's hot
is not i'm not gonna change that because
it makes you feel uncomfortable because
and by the way that's not like
it's not it's not a wrong thing to do
it's just oh this guy is trashy or bummy
yeah that's okay for them to think that
i'm 100 okay i could live happy for the
rest of my life somebody thinking that
it doesn't matter they're not important
to me because i'm not doing something
culturally offensive i'm not doing
something bad or wrong it's just i just
look like a bum
to them
you know like being at the airport like
in korea and dressing you see people go
you see people going to in the airport
from korea to
to the us which is a very long flight
full makeup dressed up and i'm like
you're going to be on a plane
what are you doing you always got to be
ready for anything or anything that's
their mentality
my mentality is that if something goes
down in an airport i need to be flexible
quick and ready to run yeah i was like i
want to be comfortable i'm going to
sleep there yeah well i think that's
what's great about america and i'm
really thankful in that kind of sense is
that although like i grew up in the
asian community where it is very emp
emphasized on
saving your face
i still have this other side like me as
an adult
living and working in american side
where
none of that really matters
um it's just you be you and you do your
job well and you be a good person
then
i'm happy
yeah that makes me happy yes i make
these like racist not racist but i make
these certain
i take certain actions because i'm used
to doing that and people might take it
offensive if they don't know me but if
they know me they'll be like oh that's
marielle
but in korea that would be like a gossip
i wouldn't able to do that
yeah i think you're a lot different than
i mean you know it's like i've i've kind
of grown up people judging me my whole
life it can't stop me from doing stuff
that makes me happy or feel comfortable
like me you are that's like
it's just so hard for me to
worry about what this person's thinking
because what you think doesn't make me
uncomfortable you're not a people
pleaser like definitely not like i'm
definitely not a [ __ ] people this is
where again we're and this is like we're
polar opposite where i'm such a people
pleaser
and you're not and it's just so so
exhausting living like that it is
exhausting but also
it also makes me happy listen i've
i mean you're not that bad of a people
pleaser though like i've met people
pleasers who get under my [ __ ] skin
because they're just so [ __ ]
obnoxious like i can't even be around
them because you're always it's it's
like walking on eggshells around them
all the [ __ ] time because they can't
deal with the fact that there's somebody
out there in this world hates them oh
that i don't care that is so hard for
them like we know somebody like that too
and this person man like
just having a conversation with this
person is just they're always trying to
figure out if they did something wrong
or if you like them and it's just like
that's a good lord man just shut the
[ __ ] up oh i could care less about
people i don't know it's just like why
do you do this man out of sight out of
mind for me
also i have a memory of a golfer and the
funny thing is because they don't
understand too it's like because you're
such a people pleaser people hate you
oh
does somebody hate me
it has the opposite effect you're such a
people pleaser people [ __ ] dislike
you because the biggest problem with
people pleasers is that they always tend
to be dishonest
uh they can't be true to themselves they
can't be true to themselves because
they're true to everybody else yeah and
their ideals so they only do things
based on what what other people dictate
maybe i'm not people you are not that
big you're not that big you're a people
pleaser to the people you care about yes
yeah not to everybody no so like because
you care about me a lot you want to make
sure that i'm happy and i'm always
thinking two steps ahead and i hurt
myself because yeah and then you have a
certain expectation of what you expected
out of me to feel when you tried to
people please feel like you become
disappointed yeah that's a little
different there are people pleasers out
there who literally will turn their back
on you let's say for example like i know
people pleasers who look to my face and
they'll be like oh man you're such a
good person you're a really good homie
blah blah blah and then um somebody will
be like oh isn't david an [ __ ] goes
yeah he's kind of an [ __ ] cause
they're people pleasers like that and we
have to confront those people it's like
hey bro why'd you say that it's like oh
it's not what i meant i said no it's
cause you're a people pleaser you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] made [ __ ]
and that's why people don't trust you
because all you do is go around and you
try to adhere to how everybody else
feels people pleasers are the people i'm
the most worried about because they're
the backstabbers they're the
backstabbers they can't stand their
ground to save their life therefore
koreans are people pleasers
they kind of are though right because
it's always like how many times have i
have we talked about people in church
where they look at your face
and they go i appreciate you so much i
hope you have a blessed day then they go
have their little kuyung ebe and all of
a sudden they're talking [ __ ] about you
i could already have the conversation in
my head right and then you come back the
next day and they go oh i don't know
what's happening at the church like
people are so mad and you're the one who
[ __ ] started it dude can i say can i
just tell you one story it's like it's
not about the adults or anything it's
actually
actually about an experience i had when
i was in sixth grade
this you're saying exact same thing what
you're saying although the people
pleasing part i think it is part of it
so there is this girl who i met
i went to a new school
and she wanted to be my best friend
she's like let's be best friend i'm like
okay i don't know anyone so sure
and sure enough she provided enough
evidence to say we're best friends and
i'm making the effort and i was like
this is awesome and i'm trying to get to
know other people and they're getting to
know me
time passes by and all of a sudden
i get dirty looks and i'm like huh and
then so that best friend calls me and
she's like you know i think people don't
like you i'm like but i like you so
don't worry and i'm like okay and so
she's like here let's see if they really
don't like you so there was a thing
called three-way call back then
so we would three-way call uh a
classmate
and she would pretend that i'm not there
and they would start having a
conversation and say talking about me
and then she would say
so what do you think about her and then
like i think she's all right and then
she'd be like but isn't she kind of
annoying she's kind of annoying and then
the friend the other girl would be like
yeah she's kind of annoying
i hate that i hate that so [ __ ] much
i didn't know what was going on but i
was like i'm broken what is going on
and no joke she started that flame
the entire korean community
of sixth grade
hated me
hated me so much
that i literally didn't have anyone to
hang out with and i thought
[ __ ] i'm screwed
and then on top of that she had an older
sister
she sent me an email
as if it was the older sister saying
don't [ __ ] around with my little sister
if you do anything i will kill you
it was so big the text was so big that
my mom saw it
and she got so mad it was like at
midnight
she called that
friend's mom and said what the [ __ ] is
this why am i seeing cursing word all
over saying it's your sister or it's
your daughter and the mom is like what
are you talking about and she's like so
mind blown
i think they got in trouble and somehow
that information got to school
i don't know if this is the reason why
but at the end of that year they left
they left
well you can't make death threats
that's true i guess that is a death oh
my god they probably got kicked out
because you're you kid can't make death
threats to another god i didn't know
that was a death threat yeah that's a
death threat oh [ __ ] i was just scared
and she did come around right before she
left she said sorry
she had to
i was like i had no idea what was going
on
and everybody hated me and then she left
i was like what and then the people
still hate you after
no so funny enough the following year
when we went to seventh grade everyone
was nice it was like a restart again
yeah and i i told myself i was like [ __ ]
this i'm gonna be the nice guy i'm gonna
be a [ __ ] and don't [ __ ] talk to me
that's what i was thinking in my head so
i never said hi to anyone and i just
like walked around like i don't give a
[ __ ] and people started saying hi to me
people i don't i don't even know they're
like hi
and i'm like see look at that when you
don't [ __ ] care and you don't look
but but that's to my point though right
yeah when you when you
listen it's great to lean on people for
strength but those people that you lean
on to strength have to be people who are
important to you in your life you know
that are kind people
but when your foundation is strong and
you're unfuck-witable
like people will respect that you know
even like like people sometimes even
confuse this right they go well i'm a
geek and i'm a nerd blah blah blah it's
like you can be a confident geek and a
[ __ ] confident nerd bro like
do you have any idea dude some of my
favorite people on youtube that i watch
they're the dweebiest nerdiest
[ __ ] on earth and they they
just lose confidence they ooze this this
this like charisma charisma and you kind
of fall in love with that like oh this
is really cool to see this person kind
of shine in their realm because they
believe in themselves yes they and they
also just they don't give a [ __ ] they
enjoy what they enjoy they like what
they like whether you like what i
[ __ ] like doesn't [ __ ] matter i
have a community that [ __ ] with me and
then we all share our joy together and
that's what [ __ ] matters you know
what
that's when i met becky
oh really
hilarious yeah it was just it was a it
was such a funny time wearing i was in
the bathroom cleaning my wide-ass shoes
he's our best friend becky's my best
friend since seventh grade and i was
just cleaning my white shoe to keep it
clean and i'm like don't [ __ ] with me
because i'm cleaning my shoes and then
she comes around she's like hi
with this high-toned voice i'm like
she's still there
[Applause]
and she
really showed me what friend meant but
yeah prior to that i didn't really have
good experience with korean girls
yeah it's hard it's i mean developing
strong friendships is difficult but when
you find like that special person it it
clicks really hard there are people who
people that's what i'm saying man some
of y'all throw out that word friend too
easy and you kind of set yourself up for
disappoint because every time you meet
somebody and you have a good interaction
one interaction you go oh this person's
my friend they are not your [ __ ]
friend
you had they are just a good
acquaintance right now yeah friendship
is a title that is earned it is
something that is earned through trials
tribulations like misunderstandings
going back and forth on things
that's what like
it's hard making good friends it's not
easy it's not and
i don't know it's not and i don't know
why but i had a flashback of people at
work who i met or now like good friends
of mine because
we worked
so many hours together gone through so
much [ __ ] together that we're friends
now and you were saying like it's hard
to earn that friend term
and it's hard to make friends too
especially as an adult i think it's not
as easy because we're not like in a
campus college and just like meeting
people but
um
i don't know why i always just i mean
it's simple like i you know me and joe
talked about this on a previous podcast
where people just it's called [ __ ] on
the first date you guys you guys just
[ __ ] on the first date and it's true
that's what like i think girls do this
the most
because a lot of my home girls go
through these same issues they go
besties forever
bless
you know best friends this is my best
deal we're living our best life and the
next thing i can't believe she did this
it's like [ __ ] you just [ __ ] met her
what you mean you can't believe it you
best believe it you don't [ __ ] know
her when i see people like that i'm like
you're not my friend i don't want to get
anywhere near you because i don't know
when you're giving this same advice to
marielle too it you know not that long
ago or it was like i forgot how long ago
was whatever the timeline doesn't matter
but you know going through like these
thoughts of her just like stressing out
about certain people in her life and i
asked her like are these people your
friends and then she paused and she was
like i guess i was like then that's
they're not your friends like if you
have to go uh they're not your friends
that means they're people that are maybe
in your social circle yeah yeah so don't
get hurt or affected by what these
people say because their opinions do not
matter yeah you know that's true you
cannot let peop that's why you have to
be careful and i c and i warn people
about this all the time telling people
that they're or knowing who your
acquaintances are who your friends are
who your homies are and who your
brothers and sisters are are very that's
the thing sometimes you feel like you're
friends because you go you dive in deep
way too fast and too deep
on the first date
i guess that is true yeah
or yeah we're to the point you're like
oh my god we know each other so much
and we're okay with it and then like
also you become friends but actually
that's not the case because you don't
know how they are day to day you you
don't yeah you really [ __ ] don't man
and then sometimes too when you feel
like you're about to be at that friend
level and you start getting you like oh
you we're actually don't we don't
actually get along yeah yeah we're not
we're very different yeah and then you
fizzle out you become acquaintances you
know what i think for my problem it's
not people pleasing but it's the fact
that oh somebody wants
wants like needs my help not me it's my
helpo
wants to get my
advice maybe or someone who's wanting me
i think that's like very rare for me
like i'm like oh my god they appreciate
my presence like i i feel that way
sometimes and i think when that happens
and they talk about they're very open or
vulnerable with me
i'm like
i feel so appreciated but
they probably have no idea that's how i
feel yeah and also too that's that's a
relationship that's not even a
relationship it's a one-way street
right and we were talking about this too
about how
when sometimes when you meet people and
they kind of open up and they dump
everything on you and every time you
meet them the only thing they talk about
is their pain their struggles and
themselves that's not a friendship
you're their free therapist you are
their emotional tampon you have to
absorb all their [ __ ] all their emotions
right
and then what
because what happens when their problems
are solved like do you guys have a still
have a friendship what else is there to
talk about nothing because they're not
talking about themselves those aren't
friendships i've met people like that so
much where they take they take they take
and they go oh this person's really
close to me no
you feel like you're close to me because
you get everything from this
relationship you know what i realize
i think that's what youtubers are
you know how
so like tv hollywood celebrities and
youtubers like the fans react
differently and i think it's because
youtubers are so open they receive
everything they think they know
everything about them so they're like oh
my god we're friends
that's why they react like friends when
they meet you or anyone which for me
like i don't mind as long as they
understand boundaries yeah there is no
better because they're like hey we're
brothers like as long as i mean i've had
some people come up to me and be like
we're twins we're exactly the same and
i'm like you need to get your clammy
hands off me don't you think that's why
though
i mean you know what the youtube
relationship is very unique right
because i tell almost everything about
not even everything you guys hear about
50 about my life that i feel comfortable
telling
um
and you get to know my thoughts and my
struggles and the biggest thing about i
think why people like my youtube so much
is because i was the average joe
i i was not even maybe not even the
average joe i was the geeky chubby asian
dude that was loud mouth and didn't give
a [ __ ] you didn't see that a lot like
the people who who who pretended like
they didn't give a [ __ ] which by the way
there's not a lot of people who
talk like me and i've gotten to know
this a lot especially in these social
circles talk like you what do you mean
talk like like say [ __ ] and not give a
[ __ ] about the consequences it's like
this is how i feel if i'm not hurting
anybody's feelings if these are just
thoughts and opinions if you don't like
it that's okay i i enjoy that you don't
like it because you're also allowed to
have your opinion so there's a korean
celebrity who's just like you
he was anti for the longest time and now
people love him yeah well people just
because they get sick of the people who
put up the fake front you know and i
think that's what really helped up my
youtube career in the beginning was i
was very open with my flaws i was very
open with just being a goofy looking
dude i never dressed up people didn't
even know you know in my first youtube
videos oh every shirt that i wore was a
free shirt
it hasn't changed david this isn't
official
i don't know what you're talking about
this is a human-made t-shirt this [ __ ]
was a hundred dollars human-made
t-shirts it's the brand it's pharrell's
brand oh well i mean
you get a lot of free shirts though
no i'm talking about car wash shirts i'm
talking about like [ __ ] like that like
[ __ ] at flea markets like you like that
was like a joke that i have because it
was like i didn't want people to
you don't need anything to be funny but
being a funny person you don't have to
dress a certain way you don't have to
try to dress up none of that [ __ ] so i
was completely fine being a bummy trashy
dude and so i i wore all free shirts in
my first like a majority of my videos
when i was doing these vlogs like what
is this guy's such a terribly dressed
person they were all free clothes and i
just kind of kept this inside joke going
until i was like this is pointless but
nobody gets it yeah it was just
something i did for myself you know
and
it just there's just a certain level of
freedom with it and i think that's why i
got to connect with a lot of people is
because
i'm the average joe that speaks what
most people want to say
and i just do it who's not afraid to say
it and hear
and by the way when i say i'm not afraid
to say it doesn't mean i'm right it's
just i'm also i want to be an advocate
of people to be able to discuss their
thoughts even if they're wrong because
it's just discussing and topics
that's all that it is and just stop
taking [ __ ] so [ __ ] personally
everybody takes everything so [ __ ]
personally they think that when somebody
says something that they don't agree
with that they hate them let's shut the
door or just don't say it if that's like
your fear and you don't want to see that
then don't put it out there yeah just
shut the [ __ ] up that's the best that's
the best advice you could ever you have
to share everything on social media oh
people don't know that though they feel
like they have to they feel like oh i
have to do a comedy video today oh i
have to do uh that's their job but it's
not their job though it's like you don't
have to and then when people don't like
it they delete it it's like dude who
cares did you enjoy it did you like it
if you liked it leave it up it's fine
like don't worry about it like that true
like i think what is it it's like
social media used to be something that
like you know just friends can do it and
have fun but now it became like
it has to grab everyone's attention um
it needs to have the best likes the best
blah blah blah
and i'm like i'm going
personally for me i'm like i'm going the
exact opposite
i'm telling people i'm telling you guys
right now nobody gives a [ __ ] about you
and that is a good thing
nobody cares about you as much as you
think you care about them they don't
if you die tomorrow these people that
you think actually care about you will
will cry for you one day and then forget
you the next and those are the type of
people that you're worried about [ __ ]
them you need to be worried about the
people that are in your corner that care
about you those are the ones that are
going to cry those are the ones that are
going to look at the pictures and go
back to your gravesite and then think
about all these like times that you guys
had together those are the people that
matter every time you focus and every
second you focus on people that could
give a literal [ __ ] about you who cares
that's why now like all my comments i
like all the comments because i want
people to know that i'm
at least paying attention to them at
least the people who support this
channel yeah because if i don't do that
it's like why do i always give attention
to these people who talk [ __ ] i know why
do you because it's fun for me but now i
do it too for now i'm trying to interact
more with the happy ones yeah because
they're the ones supporting you yeah but
the other ones too it's a fun game it's
like okay how do i roast this person
in a very creative and funny way it's
just an exercise then maybe you should
tell all your supporters hey put
something hate and then i will you know
respond no no they all get responses
whether it's all good ones get responses
too the bad ones get responses but
the people they enjoy it too they also
enjoy the funny little roasts you know
so it's a fun little thing that we all
do it's an exercise you know and that's
not what people are really good at i
think that's the hard part that you
actually enjoy roasting others because
that's not easy
yeah and i think also too like she knows
it too like i don't
brood over these things like i just put
it up and i go
like one like one
i've seen you maybe you were
brainstorming what you want to say but
i've seen you been like addicted to your
phone for a long time to figure out how
to roast these people yeah but that's
not me brooding over it though i hope so
i don't know
i don't i don't get involved with your
work so i'm no wha what do i mean by
brooding over it though just be talking
about and be mad about it yeah when do i
ever do that
i think you have but when tell me when
ah this is where you pissed me off
because why would i remember when
exactly because i don't
that doesn't okay just because i don't
remember doesn't mean it never happened
no you have to give me at least one
example i don't plan i i didn't i never
planned to give you this as an example
so it's not restored in my brain i'm
sorry it's been removed it's not
important for me you have to give me but
that's what i'm saying you can't say
those things without giving examples i
didn't say it i thought i saw it though
i could say that i've seen it
okay on july 28th 2020
at five o'clock now you're being a
pedantic like how you have to i'm saying
that i can't i don't write these downs
and remember you on the other hand love
to remember
this is what i mean by brooding over it
has somebody ever written a comment and
then all day i'm pissed off
ever has there been one time that has
ever happened
i feel like one day you
were and then you called it off
you were like oh i can't i'm not i can't
say you feel like that means it didn't
happen i feel like i've seen it no you
know that's impossible
you literally are just doing this now
just so you could prove your point no
give me an example from what point
there's no point give me an example you
know i forget it you never brutal how
about that
brutal you never burl give me an example
because i have to know
okay that's
i like how you because you've never had
and i said okay it never happened
because it never happened that's what
exactly what i said davidson the only
things that pissed me off that i brewed
over all day is [ __ ] that she says
that's about it which is the point right
now she just says things just to say
things like that's what i'm saying i say
brood all day she goes oh i've seen you
get upset at comments i didn't say i
don't get upset at comments what i said
is like does it ruin my whole day does
it does it ruin your whole day i said no
it doesn't then it never happened then
why did you say it did
do you see how the conversation did you
see how ridiculous she's been
oh my god she goes oh you brewed over
i'm like when she goes i don't know then
what are you talking about yeah yeah you
win you win
thank you jesus dude
her point on this podcast is just to
make me look bad as possible
sure why not so this is the [ __ ] that
pisses me off about her dude she just
says things she literally just says
things with absolutely no proof or
examples and she goes it happens and i'm
like when
that's why the word i feel are added
you can't say i feel about that stuff
when it never happened therefore i said
okay it never happened why do you have
to keep it
i feel mariel is a stupid idiot
why see i don't know because i feel like
you do stuff that say did you stupid
then why are you with me huh you should
break up with me then see that that's
not that's not her always responds i
just did something that she did right
back to me and she doesn't like it yeah
because you know because i know you
don't understand it's just how i feel
though why oh see it's just how i feel
why are you with me it's just how i feel
see that that's her always go to
response when she has nothing else to
say she goes then why are you with me
so i'm like then why are you with me oh
because that's how i feel
that's how you feel that's how i feel
i have i have no proof i'm not i have no
i have no evidence
i have no evidence but i'll just say it
because that's how i need my therapist i
can't deal with this anymore
okay you have no therapist right now all
right oh my god god help me god is not
here right now either he backed up
he's like i can't help you david was a
pastor for three years i'm on his side
this is why i fired david he
cannot become a pastor you will kill the
kids you will kill the kids
there she goes with those accents again
what accent
dude sit properly what is this i don't
wanna see your junk i'm just talking
about it's not my junk oh my gosh
whatever i don't have any accent i just
speak how i speak okay
you do have accents i have my own oh
really when you when you met uh joe's
girlfriend
hello
[Laughter]
that is one of my many hellos i was like
what the [ __ ] you know what in front of
hannah i would have to only asian actors
oh really i was like
really i was like what the [ __ ] are you
doing ain't from british or anything
she ain't from england or anything she
is she's from the uk
no she's welsh she's from the uk she's
from europe
she has a european accent and you're
like hello
you know
no she's she lives in london right now
but actually i don't know
i don't know much about her so whatever
i can't i can't deal with it oh really
you know what i'm still [ __ ] okay so
here's the thing if i have only my asian
accent with her is that cool i think
that's not the point i'm not trying to
think oh my god you're english i'm gonna
talk in my english that's what you did
though and then when you saw the asian
person you went thank you
you have to moderate this in your head
it's gonna backfire on you one day i'm
scared for your life because one day
they're gonna be like what the [ __ ] are
you doing and you'll be like what what
am i doing
you're gonna get nervous and then the
action's gonna stick like you're making
fun of me i'm not making fun of you i
just can't stop
it's like what you mean
what this is
what do you mean my name is mary poppins
and then you can't stop and you start
crying i can't stop this
this is all i can do i'm cursed
i'm cursed every i'm so nervous oh my
god you know what happened actually what
this reminds me i don't know what the
hell i was thinking it just happened
where i long long long time ago after i
came back from oh hold on one sec
continue
is ed here
i think ed is here oh ed is here oh hi
ed wait a second please um so when i
came back from taiwan can i text him
so uh we have a ed park coming into the
podcast real quick
uh i don't have oh i do i do yeah what
do i tell him hold on a second
wait for him not just open the door for
him
how'd you know that's here
[Music]
[Music]
should i resume
go ahead so when i came back from taiwan
i had this interview with a studio
this is quite embarrassing for me but so
when i came back i had you know some
struggle
getting the conversation going with
folks because i just was in a different
country my brain was in a different
world it was very
asian but not so asian at the same time
and i was having a conversation with the
studio who had french folks
and they had
accents
my interview all of a sudden i had an
accent
i just ended up having an accent i'm
like but it wasn't their accent i'm
gonna say that it wasn't a french accent
it was just like amazon talking like i
can't stop and then they looked at me
and they're like oh did you live in
australia i guess it was an aussie
accent i'm like no i did live out of
country for a bit and i think i just
hung out with so many folks that i have
a mixed accent right now
but you know i think that's her
people-pleasing problem there
it's so weird i couldn't get out of it
and it was coming out so smoothly too
but it wasn't anyone's specific country
accent i think it was just a mix that i
just got used to i hate that about you
so annoying
it's so easy how was that people
pleasing though it wasn't because you do
that in order to like it's like a
defense to make somebody feel
comfortable but it wasn't they were like
distracted because they're like where
are you from dude whenever she sees like
my my friend lynn like she's like oh
okay girl what's that like i'm like what
the [ __ ] why are you talking like that
dude no i don't do that
i might have done that once david you
have done it multiple times well you
mean multiple times every time she comes
up okay girl yes
and then until i brought it up to her i
was like i hate it when you do that
you're like what you mean
it's like what you mean
just because you don't like it i'm gonna
do it more because i do it at work i
used to do it at work do not do that i'm
gonna do it i'm telling you people pick
that up and they're like what the [ __ ]
like don't do that because you always
tell me like when you do this like to
give you a heads up and i'm giving you a
heads up okay bye
i feel like i'm gonna burn myself if i
don't listen yeah i'm telling you but it
wasn't people pleasing i think it just
like it's like a nervous tech that you
have
i don't know what the hell that is you
know like how if you're with the koreans
and they speak only korean then you
start speaking korean it's kind of like
that i think i think i was just like oh
i'm in a foreign environment my foreign
side is coming yeah we talked about this
too where it's like code switching right
um yeah people do that a lot in order to
make other people either feel
comfortable or make them feel
comfortable you're going with their
energy yeah i'm i'm
i mean we all do that to a certain
extent that was me yeah but yours is
extreme though hello okay like no nobody
code switches as hard as you do the way
you code switch is crazy though it's
like you'll you'll be you you need like
an aussie person putting some strips on
the bobby
like what the [ __ ] are you doing your
coat switching is hella hard it's fun
no i'm saying that though i think
in my defense i lived in so many
different areas that
i do have a friend who's just like me
where they just just start saying random
accents for no reason
something like that yeah so they'll just
like i don't know meet like an african
dude they go hello what is your name
possibly possibly what do you want to
eat i don't know what i want to eat
i mean okay let's not go that far
but you know if you're for example if
you're with a korean person who speaks
korean a lot
i start talking in konglish
well that's different because you're
doing that because that's the
communication's easier
the communication isn't easier with
hannah when you go hello
it's just that's how my brain thinks
okay that's fine maybe you don't
understand maybe just don't understand
maybe someone out there will understand
i understand that's fine but i'm telling
you it's gonna bite you in the ass
what
should i just not talk no when you see
an asian person
and you go sound cute like that's good
honestly would okay if there's an
american per a white person in front of
me and i say sound cute do you think
they would understand no because they're
not asian
so why would the white person get
offended by that i'm not saying getting
offended but they wouldn't understand
what are you talking about i want to
know what sound q mean like if i say
thank you well thank you so much yes i
the chinese person would have understood
if you said thank you if you just said
thank you no not i was trying to see
that's what i'm saying it's a korean
version thank you
i was using karina i said thank you
if you just would have said thank you it
would have been perfect perfectly fine
i'm just giving you a heads up that you
continue to do that you're gonna find
one person that's not gonna [ __ ] with
that and it's gonna be a bad bad look
like like when you come came up and you
asked one of my closest friends khalif
if you could touch his hair yeah yeah it
was lucky that it was khalifa and it
wasn't some other random person that you
just met do you see what i'm saying so
what should i do
just think twice
when i see
let me be a very slow talker with
somebody who has an accent maybe i
shouldn't use an accent okay i didn't
know that person didn't have an accent
and it honestly didn't even look at that
person i just said thank you i didn't
even like i wasn't cautious about not
cautious but like i wasn't thinking
oh that person is asian probably doesn't
know english let me say thank you with
an accent i wasn't thinking like that i
know you don't think that but you do
these things quite often so i'm just
trying to give you a heads up because
you told me to tell you when you do
these things
because like in the work setting you
might mess up
and you know what's happened to you
quite a few times so i'm trying to give
you a heads up
you just told me you did an interview
with in an aussie accident and you
couldn't stop
that was a long long long time ago
so i'm trying to help you out that was
way before i met you
hello
i didn't do that it was just like very
minor accent just don't do it why not
just what do i do with my american
accent then what american accent
i'm thinking when i'm
talking what are you saying are you high
you know what i feel high right now
neither am i okay fine thank you for
your advice i will accept it and i'll be
more cautious yeah i'm i'm trying to
look out for you
all right i just don't want you to get
your ass beat one day i'll never leave
the house i'm too scared and i'm like
hey why did you beat up my wife and they
go well i was walking around and she
kept mocking me to try to imitate my
accent i'm like oh i understand she just
does these
it considered things
if i live there though and i
like if i'm doing korean accent am i
mocking them
yes it doesn't matter if because if if
they just want to be spoken to regularly
in america in english and you go up then
you go and then you start you know
speaking to him in a korean accent it's
like what the [ __ ] oh yeah i mean i
wouldn't do that
but you do do that
what are you talking about hannah yes
you did hannah i
well i'm saying you're very lucky
because hannah's okay with that but i
have seen other people be like what the
[ __ ]
you know like to me no not to you okay
but they'll be like hello oh you have
you have a british you have a british
accent and they're like dude cut that
[ __ ] out i've seen that so i'm saying no
i'm not doing that
does hannah no i'm not very bad oh she
knows because she talked to you and
you're [ __ ] goofy as [ __ ] but i'm
saying you're lucky because you got to
do it yeah yeah
but you do to another stranger who
doesn't find that funny or endearing
because they don't know you that's when
it could get a little troubling i'll try
i don't i i hope i'm
uh
reactive and fast enough where i could
stop myself because it's not for me
where it embarrasses me i'm worried and
i'm like please don't get beat up
okay please don't beat up mike well
number one i don't leave the house much
so
maybe you should huh
maybe that's the problem maybe it'll
help out a little bit yeah maybe all
able to monetize dude whenever like lynn
would come like lynn you know lynn grew
up in stockton and stuff talking
vietnamese okay okay that was a little
racist
wait wait
i don't talk in vietnamese she said
vietnamese accent no but you don't do a
vietnamese accent but
she grew up in you know limbs from
stockton and stuff onto sacramento so
you know like we co-switch a lot and
it'll come out so with her she'll see
lynn she goes
okay girl what you cooking i don't think
so
you know yes you do
[Applause]
that's right you like calling me out
i've called you out too what
there was one time when we went over and
lynne was cooking for and that's when
you put it on super hard and i remember
after that i told i asked you why do you
do that and you're like i do what oh my
gosh
oh [ __ ] but here's the thing i it is
true when peop
i get
very very easily influenced by how
people talk around me so if you talk
like that i will start picking it up
yeah and like i said like i understand
when people code switch light and say
you co-switch hard like it's crazy it's
like night and day
yes that's who i am you know what i'm
saying like that's how i pick up
languages i can do the whole thing right
when i talk to like a white executive
and be like hey how are you you know i
could do all that stuff yeah right but
if i'm talking casually and you know
when it gets later and later at night my
sacramentality starts to come out oh
dude yeah you turn into a whole
different person when you're with
certain zack friends i'm like i
what happened to my dave
that's how i grew up talking a majority
of my life
and then um somewhere in between like me
trying to get a professional job and all
this other stuff i started recording how
i spoke and i started switching on i
started practicing like stop saying you
know what i'm saying you feel me like i
took all this stuff out i stopped saying
the n-word i stopped doing all this
stuff so
you know it was practice over time but
obviously when you get tired when it
gets late at night you start drinking
you speak the way that you normally do
yeah where you're just see that's me
except it's not the tire part this is
what i mean by like i don't have an
accent i don't have a language is that i
grew up
you grow up for example a certain accent
certain style of conversation and then a
certain time you're like i gotta switch
it so you've established that foundation
i don't have that foundation i grew up
very mumbly like
washy wishy washy gray line and then i
picked up languages and then this is
your normal talk right here though this
is it this is
my
normal when i'm concentrating but when
i'm like loosey-goosey and i'm not
really thinking how i'm talking then it
just comes out however i like yeah like
it's like it's like your dreams you know
you
people ask me how do what language do
you dream
what language do you use when you're
dreaming i say i don't know
it depends because i've heard recently
it's all english because that's all i
speak but then in the past i have spoken
all languages that i learned yeah
i mean like i said i get it but yeah i
understand you know what i'm talking
about i do know what you're talking
about i just want to explain where i'm
coming from that i'm not trying to
pretend
like i said there's not a hateful
harmful bone in your body yes yes at all
it's just why it doesn't come out so
easy you're the example of just pure
ignorance and bliss like ignorance is
bliss you're that example because
because it's not like if marielle does
something that's culturally offensive
she doesn't double down and defend and
she goes oh is that offensive why
she's not the person that doubles down
on something she does wrong she'll ask
why yeah and they'll explain she goes oh
okay
you know yeah
one time we were i forgot we were
watching this uh the soul food
documentary and out of nowhere she just
asked she goes how come black people
like fried chicken so much
i'm like
okay what the [ __ ] what do you mean
right
yes and it was a fried chicken section
right and then i was like explain
yourself she goes because korean people
love fried chicken too so how come they
get it wait are you sure that was me
that was you
and then i was cracking up and i'm like
okay let's just uh and then we talked
about watermelon too because you're like
how come they they say how come like why
people say you know black people love
watermelons yeah that one and then
you're like i don't get korean people
love watermelon
everybody likes watermelon everybody
likes water which is true i think it was
just some racial stuff back in the day
that stuck
yeah yeah yeah it was like some kind of
song no no that was the ice cream man
song that was some other stuff but see
when she asked these questions and most
people would be like why is she asking
that it's because she didn't grow up
here you know these are like cultural
stuff that if you're not from here or if
you weren't surrounded by a certain
culture you're not gonna know these
things no matter how mainstream it is
because what's mainstream to you might
not be mainstream to somebody else oh
yeah absolutely even at work when
they're talking about mainstream
hollywood stars
i have no idea what they're saying
that's what it's like when i go to these
meetings and they talk about film people
they're like oh did you watch the film
by you know jacques by pewd
and i'm like [ __ ] yes i did it was
beautifully shot it was a masterpiece
and they're like yeah what did you like
about us like the cinematography the
lighting the gaffers
i agree and i walk away i'm like who the
[ __ ] is that like i have no idea who the
[ __ ] that is i just smile and no i'm
like yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm i'm like
stop me stop now i just go i have no
idea who that is oh me too i mean uh
when they start having that conversation
and i have to be involved i'm like i'm
gonna peace out because i don't
understand do film people love talking
to you about like directors and like i
don't know anything as if i should know
i know the movies that i enjoy and know
but you're talking about like a 1950s
film i don't [ __ ] know that far back
yeah well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast i
hope you enjoyed that one this woman
says that apparently i'm over here just
just brooding in negative comments which
is so not true
i walk around most of the time and i'm
happy every day you are such a filthy
liar you code switcher anyways
that's what i said never mind the person
that gets under my skin is this woman
here there's like literally nobody else
and i'm so innocent too and you're
trying to get you dressed like a ninja
turtle today
i love it
but anyway you can catch mario at meriel
underscore underscore song she also has
her own podcast with her friends called
lip lipp ladies in production podcast
yeah you remember because i'm a good
husband that's why l-i-p-p lip
ladies in podcast production they're
ladies and production podcasts
yeah it's called ladies and prod
podcasts yes you can catch them they're
on their second season right now give it
a listen give it a go
uh genius brains every thursdays and
sundays all the way until january 1st
after january 1st it's going to be once
a week my friends but for now twice a
week and then we will see you all next
time